what would happen if you fell into  quicksand  well it's not exactly like what we see  in the movies that's because quicksand  is rarely deep enough to submerge your  entire body but at times it can be deep  enough and if you fell into quicksand  and started to panic you would only go  down faster and deeper you could get  pulled under and drown or get stuck and  become bait for predators  if you do find yourself in this  situation the trick is to stay calm take  off any heavy items you're wearing and  start to lean back  this allows water to move into the gaps  you're creating making it easier to move  now try to grab a stick and pull  yourself out but this won't be easy as  pulling your body out of quicksand  requires the same amount of force as you  would use to lift a small car  if you did manage to escape you'd  probably end up with some injuries but  it's better than drowning in quicksand i  guess  you know what i've always wondered